je vais me tourner vers jorge semprun et
lui demander au fond c'est la question
je vais lui poser parce que je crois
qu'il est très importante pourquoi vous
espagnol voulions à paris depuis
longtemps mais pourquoi vous écrivain de
langue espagnole vous avez choisi
d'écrire la plupart de vos livres et les
beaux romans en dans la langue française
en fait je n'ai pas choisi d'écrire un
français au départ
au départ je choisis de maîtriser le
français
en 1939 quand je suis arrivé après la
fin de la guerre civile espagnole
j'avais 16 ans je lisais le franchit
correctement je l'écrivais un petit peu
mais je lui parlais très mal et donc de
pour tout le monde j'étais étranger jeux
de l'époque où cette xénophobie latente
chez vous se concentrer sur les rouge
espagnole de l'armée en déroute
là je voulus par une ruse de guerre
effacer cette condition du rouge
espagnole de l'armée en déroute du moins
à l'apparence et donc apprendre le
français pour être absolument
indiscernable vachement je pensais pas
écrire en français je pensais que je
crée à l'espagnol ce qui était prévu
j'avais 7 ans si on l'avait décidé à la
famille façon la famille reza qu'il crée
ou de la politique je ferai j'ai
d'ailleurs je fais de l'un à l'autre
donc c'était une espèce de ruse de
guerre j'ai appris pour ne pas être au
bout de 12 2 - gti identifiables
personne ne savait que j'étais rouge
espagnole le chablis avec moi que ça
donc en fait c'est ça la décision au
départ et puis en cours de route et
m'est arrivé
toutes proportions gardées ce qui est
arrivé à juan gris mais ce que je
corrige moby lines complètement bilingue
j'ai choisi écrire en français mais
j'écris l'espagnol pas aussi souvent
mais ça se protège agents ou de
résidence ou de censure pendant toute
l'époque franquiste
je suis content je peux écrire dans
l'une ou l'autre langue
oui bien sûr mais n'empêche que à par
l'autobiographie federico sanchez de la
plupart tous vos grands romans l'un des
clients français
oui voilà pourquoi parce que le français
est une langue admirable pour un
espagnol
parce que l'espagnol est une langue qui
a une tendance dans toutes les langues
en cette tendance là enfin un espagnol
elle est difficile à maîtriser et
tendance à la grandiloquence l emphase
une tendance à la hausse mains de
traverses voilà aux incidents tels
accompli qu'à la complexité baroque
souvent et une tendance à ce qu'on
appelle en français le mot qui n'est pas
français kitsch mais pour lequel il a un
monde espagnol parfait qui est fou si le
ca de la seule langue pour lequel il ya
un vrai mot pour geeks c'est l'espagnol
ça tient certainement une à une culture
baroque jésuitique se partager entre
espagne europe centrale alors ses
défauts la français sont beaucoup plus
faciles à maîtriser
alors quand on quand on arrive qu'on a
16 ans et qu'on découvre en même temps
baudelaire gilles rimbaud c'est c'est
évidemment un coup de foudre
oui mais alors vous avez aussi
conscience qu'en choisissant langue
française vous vous donnez moins de
chance d'être lus dans le monde entier
puisque la langue espagnole est beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui qu'avant de penser - de
change de lire de toute façon ça c'est
évident parce que même les traductions
de livres en espagnol sont plus à
l'extrait que la livre original en
france